alrededor de 1820 un físico alemán
llamado hans christian usted hizo un
experimento accidental que abrió una
nueva rama de la física la cual explora
las conexiones entre la electricidad y
el magnetismo
en este vídeo vamos a explorar cuál fue
ese descubrimiento y cuáles fueron sus
implicaciones se dice que cuando usted
estaba dando una lección en la que tenía
un cable de cobre a través del cual
pasaría corriente eléctrica y por
casualidad había una pequeña brújula
magnética sobre su mesa lo que ocurrió
fue cuando hizo pasar una corriente
eléctrica a través del cable para
realizar algún experimento la brújula
magnética se desvió eso fue todo
así fue el experimento que condujo al
gran descubrimiento ahora antes de que
hablemos sobre cuál fue repitamos ese
experimento para realizarlo todo lo que
necesitamos es un cable una batería para
dotar una corriente eléctrica al cable y
una aguja magnetizada
una vez que conectemos la batería
una vez que cerremos el circuito la
corriente va a pasar a través del cable
y vamos a observar qué le pasará a esta
aguja magnetizada bien allá vamos
observa la aguja magnetizadas se
desviará
ese fue el experimento tal vez estés
pensando por qué es tan importante este
experimento así que vamos a reflexionar
hasta ahora usábamos la electricidad
para crear calor o luz pero por primera
vez en la historia de la humanidad se
descubrió que la electricidad la
corriente eléctrica puede hacer girar
cosas puedes pensar en cuáles son las
aplicaciones de esto este principio se
usa en los ventiladores se usa en las
lavadoras en los taladros etcétera es el
mismo principio que utiliza nuestro
amperímetro y voltímetro dentro de los
cuales pasas una corriente y hay una
aguja que se desvía y nos muestra la
medición pero más importante aún este
experimento nos llevó a un gran
descubrimiento cuál es ese
descubrimiento te preguntas
bueno pensemos esto que puede ser lo que
empuja en una brújula magnética los
campos magnéticos ya hemos visto que los
imanes crean campos magnéticos y cuando
acercas una pequeña brújula a un imán el
campo magnético desvía la brújula pero
en el experimento original no hay imanes
cerca entonces que está creando el campo
magnético que mueve esta brújula
bueno como la corriente eléctrica es la
responsable de esta desviación tal vez
la corriente eléctrica induce un campo
magnético alrededor de ella
y ese fue el gran descubrimiento porque
tan grande porque antes se creía que la
electricidad y el magnetismo eran dos
fenómenos completamente separados ahora
con este simple experimento podemos ver
que la corriente eléctrica induce un
campo magnético lo que nos indica que
debe existir algún tipo de conexión
entre la electricidad y el magnetismo y
es por ello que este experimento abrió
una nueva rama en la física que llamamos
el electromagnetismo donde exploramos la
conexión entre electricidad y magnetismo
usted y algunos otros físicos estaban
emocionados por este descubrimiento y
querían aprender más sobre la conexión
entre la corriente eléctrica y el campo
magnético así que hicieron más
experimentos como este una de las cosas
que inmediatamente observaron es que se
incrementaba en la fuerza de la
corriente
entonces la desviación en la aguja
aumentaba es decir la aguja se desviaba
más eso significa que la fuerza del
campo magnético aumentó en otras
palabras encontraron que se aumenta es
la corriente automáticamente el campo
magnético aumenta esto parece obvio ya
que la corriente es la que produce el
campo magnético por lo que esperamos que
si la corriente aumenta su efecto sea
mayor y eso te dará como resultado que
el campo magnético aumente otra cosa que
encontraron es que si mantenían la misma
corriente eléctrica pero ponían la aguja
a diferentes distancias del cable
entonces el campo magnético variaba
la desviación era mayor cerca del cable
y mientras más se alejaban del cable la
desviación era cada vez menor eso
significa que el campo magnético es más
fuerte cerca del cable y cada vez más
débil mientras nos alejamos de él ese es
otro de los resultados el campo se
debilita a mayor distancia del cable una
vez más esto tiene sentido ya que es
similar a lo que pasa con un imán si
estás cerca de un imán su campo es
fuerte y sus fuerzas mayor y si te
alejas del imán el campo se debilita y
finalmente ellos querían saber cómo era
el campo magnético cómo se veían las
líneas del campo magnético y ya hemos
visto antes cómo dibujar las líneas del
campo magnético todo lo que tenemos que
hacer es esparcir un poco de limaduras
de hierro y ver cómo se organizan o
mover esta brújula magnética alrededor
del cable en varios lugares y ver cómo
se orienta para hacer esto pusieron el
cable en vertical y lo hicieron pasar a
través de una pieza rectangular de
cartón donde podrían esparcir la
limaduras de hierro o donde podían poner
todas las brújulas magnéticas y cuando
colocaron las brújulas encontraron que
las agujas magnéticas se orientaban de
la siguiente manera la punta roja
representa el polo norte del imán y la
azul el polo sur ahora recuerda que
definimos la dirección del campo
magnético como la dirección hacia donde
el polo norte apunta así que en esta
aguja el campo magnético se orienta
hacia acá en esta otra el campo
magnético se orienta hacia acá
seguimos si reemplazamos las agujas
magnéticas con flechas que representan
la dirección del campo magnético se va a
ver algo así puedes ver que las flechas
forman un círculo asi que dibujamos una
línea continua que conecta esas flechas
terminaríamos dibujando un círculo un
círculo cuyo centro es el cable y esto
significa que si quieres encontrar la
dirección del campo magnético en
cualquier punto alrededor del cable
tenemos que dibujar una tangente del
círculo si dibujamos una tangente al
círculo obtienes la dirección del campo
magnético en ese punto si dibujamos otra
tangente del círculo por acá obtenemos
la dirección del campo magnético en este
otro punto y por supuesto vamos a
realizar más prácticas para encontrar la
dirección del campo magnético en otro
vídeo pero esto es cierto para todas las
distancias incluso si nos acercamos al
cable la dirección del campo magnético
seguirá fluyendo en círculos
si nos alejamos el cable la dirección
del campo magnético seguirá fluyendo en
círculos por lo tanto el campo magnético
en cualquier lugar alrededor de un cable
recto que lleva corriente se conformará
de círculos concéntricos este es otro de
los resultados que encontraron las
líneas del campo magnético son círculos
concéntricos cuyo centro es el cable por
último se dieron cuenta que la dirección
de estas líneas del campo magnético
depende de la dirección de la corriente
si cambiamos la dirección de la
corriente las líneas seguirán siendo
círculos concéntricos pero cambiará la
dirección de esta manera
ahora observa como hemos dibujado estas
líneas del campo los círculos están más
cercanos entre sí cerca del cable lo que
indica que el campo es más fuerte cerca
del cable debemos recordar que una de
las propiedades de las líneas es que si
el campo es más fuerte entonces
dibujamos las líneas del campo magnético
más cercanas entre sí y mientras nos
alejamos del cable el campo magnético es
más débil y como resultado las líneas
del campo magnético se dibujarán más
separadas entre sí así que que
aprendimos de este vídeo aprendimos que
cuando pasas corriente eléctrica por
cualquier cable se induce un campo
magnético alrededor de él esto conecta
la electricidad y el magnetismo y con
algunos experimentos exploramos las
propiedades de este campo magnético y la
más importante de ellas es que cuando el
campo magnético se debe a una corriente
eléctrica que atraviesa un cable las
líneas del campo serán círculos
concéntricos